- My name is Siddhesh,
and I'm thrilled to have all
of you here with me.
Before we start on with the session,
a quick show of hands.
So how many of you have
any live production applications
running right now?
Almost everyone, right?
And you're here at re:Invent,
enjoying the sessions, learning.
How many of you know what you would do
if the application goes down?
Oh, fantastic.
So you're actually on the step one,
what you would do if the
application goes down.
How many of you have tested
that workflow in last 90 days?
Fantastic. Great.
So, today, I'm going to talk
about a very important aspect
of any business requirement,
which is DR,
which is business resiliency, right?
And with me, we also have Zydus,
a global pharmaceutical giant.
We will walk through their journey
of how they implemented disaster recovery
for a very complicated and
complex suit of applications
using AWS Disaster Recovery system.
But let me start with first talking to you
about the agenda for today.
So, for the longest time,
backup and disaster recovery
was done using tapes.
You have your data,
copy that to the tapes,
save the tapes at a secure location.
Anyone does that now?
I hope not.
Okay, great.
In today's time,
we have multiple architectural patterns
and solutions to give you
much faster DR.
That, too, at a much lower cost.
Of course, backup and
archival still exist,
but you also have a active-active setup,
which is much faster, near real time.
But that also comes at a cost.
You also have multi-AZ deployments,
which cloud offers you.
Again, there's a different cost angle
to that, right?
So DRS gives you the benefit
of a much more efficient disaster recovery
at a lower cost, right?
So you get the benefit of near,
in sub-seconds RPO,
and few minutes of RTO,
without taking the entire cost
of active-active setup.
So, today, we have Mr. Ravi,
chief financial officer for Zydus,
who will talk to us
about what their applications are,
give us a brief overview of the company.
And then I'll talk about how DRS
helps you solve the DR problem.
How do you set up a lifecycle
of disaster recovery using DRS solution?
And, finally, we have Ashish,
our enterprise architect,
who will give a short demo
of how the service actually works
and talk about how we architected
the solution for Zydus,
not only from the backup perspective,
but how we architected the network.
How did we achieve security and resiliency
for their environment using AWS DRS?
Well, with this, I would like
to invite Mr. Ravi
to talk about Zydus and give us a overview
of the problem statement.
- Hello.
Good afternoon, everyone.
My name is Ravi Yadavar, as Siddhesh said.
Thank you, Siddhesh, for the introduction.
I'm the chief financial officer
for Zydus in US operations.
So, first two slides,
I'm going to talk about
what Zydus is about.
And one more slide on the challenges,
what we faced with the
current DR solution,
what we have.
And the last slide, before
I hand it over to Siddhesh,
like what is the scope
or what is the expectation from AWS
to help us with the DR solution?
With this, if you can see on the screen,
like, Zydus is one
of the global pharmaceutical company.
Founded in 1952,
headquartered in Ahmedabad,
which is like in India.
It's India-based pharmaceutical company.
Having grown into more
than 29,000 employees worldwide.
And we also have business operations
in multiple countries.
Like, India is the main.
The second largest is US.
We also have a business in Europe.
Like, many countries in Europe.
Brazil and Mexico.
And many other like emerging markets.
If you see the screen,
like, we have business offices
in multiple locations in the world.
And, also, we have 41
manufacturing plants.
Out of 41 manufacturing plants,
we have like 16
US FDA-approved facility,
nine formulation, five PIs,
one biologics, and one animal health,
all catering to the US market.
And, also, we have eight R and D centers
(indistinct) this year.
The group aspires to transform their lives
through path-breaking discoveries.
So not only do we have
(indistinct) company in the US,
but globally, we would like to go
into like that discovery-based,
RNC-based company.
That's the way we want to like grow.
We are, as I said, 29,000 employees.
So I will talk a little bit
about the R and D initiatives, innovation,
what we have taken, in the next slide.
So if you look at this slide,
like we are talking about,
we have almost,
more than 1,500 research
scientists working
across 19 sites, developing on many
like NCEs, biosimilars,
vaccines, and many niche technologies,
developing into many new products
for across the globe.
So we can see that we are more focusing
on like NCEs, peptides,
monoclonal antibodies,
formulation development,
and the nutraceuticals.
And we recently like
published or announced
our positive results of,
positive results on like
our pivotal phase IIb,
phase II and III clinical trials
for Saroglitazar in adult patients
in primary, like for PBC treatment
for adult patients.
And we expect to submit our FDA
the beginning of next year.
And we expect the product to be launched
in beginning of 2027.
This will be our first NCE product
coming out of our research facility,
which is based in India.
So we take pride in saying
that we'll be the first
company introducing NCE
from our facility.
So having said this very high-level brief
of what Zydus is about,
we'll talk about, quickly,
like what is the critical
challenges Zydus faced
and which draw us to seek
for a new disaster recovery solution?
So we can focus,
like we can divide the challenge
in what we faced in
three major like hurdles
or challenges, what we faced.
The first one is like
higher RPO and RTO rate.
You may know, like RPO,
we had RPO of almost,
recovery point objective, almost 24 hours,
and RTO of like more than 24 to 48 hours.
So this high level of RPO/RTO time result
into very long recovery time of data
in case of any hardware failures
or any loss of data
or accidental deletion,
or maybe any security events,
which is not good for any pharma industry.
The extended time of getting
our shutdown results
into like delay in production
and regulatory compliance issues.
And any loss of data is
negatively looked at,
are view by regulated authorities.
And, also, any delay in
manufacturing activities
also result in delaying
in delivering product
to the needy patients.
The second hurdle or
challenge, what we faced,
is the cost and operational overhead.
As we all know,
any investment or
infrastructure investment,
building of any facilities, always,
we invest a lot of amount.
And, also, we have to spend
huge amount of money or amount
in running the facility,
operational cost and
operational complexities.
And, lastly, we can say
the security and the skilled staff.
Like, onsite disaster recovery site
is always prone to any cyber
threats, cyber incidents.
And, also, we have to hire people,
develop skilled people to run
the multiple sites,
and keep them like trained
for like application, hardware center
and other plant center locations.
So these three major challenges,
which forced us or which drove us
to seek, go to AWS, and help us
with a better disaster recovery solution.
So with this, we'll just quickly talk
about what it that we wanted.
What is the scope of the work?
What was the expectation of Zydus
from this team, AWS team, to help us?
So if you look at this,
the whole thing, what
we are talking about,
this applications or
the servers, everything,
this shows how complicated,
how complex the IT infrastructure is
for any pharmaceutical company,
like big company like ours, example.
So we have 10 mission-critical
pharma applications
running like multiple applications,
like ones here.
Sorry.
So like we have this
like lab information system,
the quality management system
or document management system,
warehouse execution systems,
and warehouse management system,
manufacture execution systems,
all these, e-log book.
All this mission-critical application
running on 60-plus like virtual,
physical, virtual servers,
running on multiple operating system,
like Windows and Linux, and also database,
like SQL database, Oracle database.
But the volume of data you use, example,
if you look at, we have almost
80-plus terabyte of data
in data center.
And there's multiple,
eight plant locations.
These are all not just cold storage data,
these are all actual
live transactional data
which requires very quick RPO time
and RTO time.
Obviously, RPO time of 15 minutes,
RTO time of less than three hours.
And, also, on top of this very quick RPO
and RTO time, we also take care
of this security and compliance issues.
Because for pharma company like us,
regulatory compliance
is not just mandatory.
It is mandated by regulatory
bodies across the world.
And every aspect of DR solution,
what we implement,
should be, like is easily validated,
it is documented, and it is audited
by the regulatory authorities.
So we have to keep in mind,
not only it is helping us
to recover the data quickly,
no loss of data,
plus it is complying with
all of the GxP requirements.
Having given all this scope,
we approached the team
and they helped us to develop
a system for us.
I'll hand it over to Siddhesh to help us
or show us what the system
they have done for us,
how they tried to achieve
our scope of objective.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, Siddhesh.
- Hey, thanks a lot, Ravi.
Thank you for giving us a brief overview
of not only the scale
of operations at Zydus, but also
the business requirements
in terms of RPO and RTO.
Well, let me just summarize
what Ravi just mentioned in terms
of business requirements.
And building this solution at Zydus' scale
was the toughest part, right?
Not only they wanted
a minimal RPO and RTO,
of 15 minutes RPO
and less than three hours RTO,
but, also, the solution has
to be cost-efficient, right?
The scale at which they operate,
with 80-plus terabytes of data,
multiple plant locations,
and these servers offer
multiple applications.
You saw (indistinct),
you saw different management systems.
All of these are deployed
across different infrastructures.
There were physical servers,
there were virtual servers.
The servers also had
multiple operating systems,
different technology stacks, right?
So the problem
was of the scale and
diversity of tech stack
and the source application.
Next is, because they have
multiple plant locations,
we had to establish secure
and resilient networking
between different plant locations
and AWS regions.
And, of course, as Ravi mentioned,
all of their software
and applications is
regulated by compliance
since they're a pharmaceutical company.
So we had to make sure
we designed the entire solution,
not only test and operate it,
but also keep it compliant.
Now, let me talk about
AWS Elastic Disaster
Recovery service, right?
But before I talk about the service,
let's just take a step back
and understand what exactly is RPO
and RTO is, very briefly.
RPO is recovery point objective.
Basically, your data loss tolerance,
how much data your
business can afford to lose
in case there is a disaster.
While RTO is recovery time objective,
which is how much downtime your business
can afford or your application
downtime tolerance.
And, of course, everybody wants RPO
and RTO to be minimum, right?
But that comes at a cost.
So there is a calculated trade-off
between how much RPO and
RTO you want to achieve
based on how much money
you're willing to spend.
Lower RPO, RTO, higher the cost,
right, and vice versa.
So Elastic Disaster Recovery gives you
a balance of RPO in few seconds,
RTO in few minutes,
and without the extensive cost
of running duplicate
servers in two environments.
Some key features of the service are,
the first one is account isolation, right?
The account or the environment
where your data is copied
is on AWS.
That's your staging environment.
That is completely
isolated from your primary.
Your primary could be on-prem,
your primary could be a
different AWS account,
or any other cloud
that is completely isolated
from your staging environment.
So if your primary is down
or compromised or impacted,
your data still remains safe
in your staging environment.
The second key feature
is immutable snapshots.
The data snapshots that DRS
takes cannot be overwritten.
This is a very strong defense
in case there is a ransomware attack
or there's a cyber attack.
Your data is intact,
your data is not corrupted.
The third key feature is it helps you
to have test drills and validation.
This is not only a best practice,
but also a compliance requirement,
that you need to periodically
test the solution
by conducting DR drills
and a validation test
to ensure your data integrity is intact
and your DR solution actually works
when there is a need
for a disaster recovery.
And the final point that I want
to talk about is it helps you
with point-in-time recovery,
which means that you can go back
to a particular snapshot,
a particular time when
your data was intact.
That's before the attack or
before the disaster happens.
So, collectively, this gives
you a very strong control
on your disaster recovery.
That, too, at a low cost.
Now, the AWS DRS is purpose-build solution
for all your disaster recovery needs.
The first key feature is it is flexible.
Your data, your service,
could be anywhere,
on-prem, cloud, hybrid, physical,
virtual, anywhere, right?
DRS supports that.
It supports wide range
of operating system,
multiple technology stacks.
The entire service is reliable,
which means that it is
non-disruptive, right?
You can perform your drills
and your tests without impacting
your production live-use case.
Without impacting your
production and live environment,
you can perform these
drills and these testing.
And all of this is highly automated.
Hence, it's easy to use.
If there is a disaster, the
last thing you want to do
is figure out which EC2 do I launch
or what are my login credentials
or how do I set up my environment, right?
This is where creating launch templates
and automating your entire process
and testing it multiple times
comes really at hand.
And, overall, it helps you to reduce
your total cost of ownership
of building a disaster recovery solution.
And at AWS, security and resiliency
is a shared responsibility, which means
that AWS takes care of security
and resiliency of the cloud,
ensuring the data is encrypted in transit,
at-rest physical security
of all your server,
of your data volumes.
And it's customer's
responsibility to make sure
and ensure security and
resiliency in the cloud.
What that means is you have to ensure
that correct monitoring, observability,
and security protocols are in place.
You set up and adopt correct backup
and DR strategy as per
your application needs,
and you test them as well.
That is customer's responsibility.
And the underlying infrastructure
is compliance ready,
which gives you a very robust platform
to build healthcare and applications,
which require different GxP compliance.
So it helps you during your audits
and compliance checks.
Now, let me talk about
the entire lifecycle
of disaster recovery service.
The step one is set up.
During setup stage, you
set up a replication agent
on your application service.
Again, your servers could be anywhere,
any operating system.
As long as you can install
a replication agent, you're good to go.
Once your replication agent
is set up on your servers,
it starts backing up your data
to the staging environment.
It does this by doing
block-level replication.
Once all your data is copied
in the staging environment,
your setup is ready and
you're good to test.
In the testing phase,
you simulate a disaster.
In that, you create recovery instances
or recovery EC2s through launch templates
in your recovery environment,
which is, again, completely separate
from your primary environment.
Once you test that your recovery workload
is up and running, data
integrity is intact,
that's the time you get
into the operating phase.
At operate phase, the agent,
the replication agent,
continuously does block-level
replication of your data.
So, and this is how we ensure
that you don't pay for
active-active setup.
You just pay for the block-level storage
that you consume to copy your data.
If there is a actual
disaster, either natural
or a cyber attack or a
human error, you failover.
During failover, you are
using your staging data,
you create your recovery instances,
and your business starts operating,
instead of from primary, through staging.
And, finally, fallback.
Fallback is equally important.
When your primary site is again up
and running post-disaster,
all your data from your
recovery environment
is copied back to your
primary environment,
and your business is up and running
from the primary site.
Now let's take a look at how this works
by taking a look at the
technical architecture.
On left, you will see
the on-premises setup,
where all your source VM exists.
Now, you have to install
a replication agent
on these source VMs.
All this data will be continuously copied
with the help of replication servers
in AWS on your staging subnet.
So what a replication server
does, it copies your data,
it reads your discs,
compresses it, encrypts it,
and sends over TCP to your staging subnet.
On staging subnet, all of this is copied
into your EBS volumes.
So the cost that you bear
is only for replication servers,
which are, again, not
full-scale production servers,
which you would otherwise use
to run your application workloads.
But replication servers
are low-cost servers
and your EBS volumes.
Both of them are, again,
comparatively much more cost-efficient.
And you also set up
your EC2 launch templates.
So launch template is where you predefine,
in case there is a disaster,
what EC2 instance do I launch?
How much, what capacity,
what configuration?
What should be my network configuration?
What should be my CIDR ranges?
And all of that.
Now, let's take a look
at what happens when there is a disaster.
When there is a disaster,
your primary site goes down.
That's when the replication servers check
that all your data is actually copied
to your EBS volumes.
Once the data integrity is tested,
then it quickly creates snapshots
using your EBS volumes.
And using the launch template
that we have defined earlier
and these snapshots, a
new environment is created
in your recovery subnet.
At this time, all you have to do
is point your network DNS
to use the recovery subnet
instead of your primary.
Right, now you're operating
in a failover mode,
where your application is entirely running
from the recovery subnet, running on AWS,
and not running
from the disaster-impacted
primary source, all right?
All of this is automated
so that if there is a disaster
at 3 a.m. at night, you don't have
to actually figure out what EC2 to launch,
where to launch it, and all of that.
All of that is already
tested, already automated,
and already defined when you do
the setup stage for DRS.
And DRS (indistinct) helps you
with building this end-to-end solution,
which you can test as often as you can,
as you want to.
Now, this is half of the DR cycle.
Now what happens when your primary site
is up and running?
So when your primary
site is up and running,
you have to fallback
from your recovery subnet
to your original primary one.
For that, you have
Failback Client installed
on your primary site, which copies
the data back from your AWS environment
to your source environment.
Once all the data is in sync,
you perform a failback.
And your, again, disaster
recovery cycle is complete.
You start running your application back
from your source environment.
And then you can decommission
the new instances
which you started in your recovery subnet.
Now, Ashish will give
us a walkthrough demo
of how this entire cycle works,
and then he'll also
give us a brief overview
of how we architected the network,
and talk to us about few learnings
while doing this for Zydus.
Ashish.
- Thank you, Siddhesh.
Thank you very much.
Good afternoon, everyone.
So as we have now learned about Zydus,
their challenges, and also how
the AWS Disaster Recovery
overall service architecture
and the compliance,
let me take you through a journey
of Zydus solution.
I mean, where Zydus started,
it was not a single month
or a year journey, multi-year journey.
They started, they wanted
to first verify how
the solution actually works
for their key requirement,
which is the minimal RPO.
And for that, they
wanted to understand how
the application-level RPO and RTO
is met with the solution.
So we created a disaster
recovery service demo,
more of a use-case demo,
where we showcased,
and we will see in a minute,
that we take an example
of a Windows-based application server
and a SQL server database, pretty normal
in the pharmaceutical
application workloads.
And then what we did
was we created an abrupt failure scenario.
We recovered that to
hundreds of kilometer away
in a different region,
and measure the RPO,
RTO, and the data integrity.
So this is how we will
see in the solution demo.
This demo required a failover scenario
and also verifying the data integrity.
It is approximately 20, 25 minutes,
and that's why we have
prerecorded this particular demo.
So let's look into the demo.
As you can see here,
we have an application server
and a database server
in a source region Mumbai,
and replicating into the Singapore region,
which is more than 4,000 kilometer,
or 4,500 miles, apart.
Let's verify the source environment.
This is a CMS application.
Let's see, in the server, also,
it's a TCP server
and running on a .NET 5
application.
Let's verify the database server,
approximately 150GB.
And to measure the RPO,
what we have done is we have created
a date script which modifies
the date table every second,
and so that we can measure the RPO
in the overall disaster scenario.
And, as you can see,
it's modifying the script.
And we will keep this running.
Let's now also
check the application-level RPO
and RTO measurement
with creating a blog post.
Now let's mimic
the exact abrupt failure scenario.
So both the server.
We will skip the operating
system shut down.
That means it may corrupt the data
or system stability issues may occur.
Majorly, generally, that's where
the disaster, whenever occurs,
this is the scenario.
And, immediately, we get to the action.
Both the servers (indistinct).
We will recover.
And if you see, we have various snapshots.
But for this particular demo,
we will use the latest snapshot
to measure the RPO.
As you can see, the job has started.
Let's also measure the
exact time of the disaster
from the CloudTrail audit API service.
During the jobs, I mean, the recovery job,
one of the key step
is the conversion process.
So, any source, as we have seen,
any source machines can
be recovered on AWS.
So this particular conversion process,
what it does is it make
changes into the boot loader
so that your source server type,
it could be a physical
server, virtual server,
Hyper-V, VMware, or any virtualization,
it can boot natively on AWS.
That's the temporary
(indistinct) server we spin up.
And, as you can see now,
the recovery is completed,
and now it's time for verification
of the data integrity.
We'll check the application server first.
As part of the recovery,
if you know the Windows operating system,
if it have done a abrupt failure,
it will give you a shutdown event tracker,
which, because of the abrupt shut down
of the operating system.
We'll start the IS server.
And meantime, it boots up,
let's check the SQL database.
Same shutdown tracker.
Let now check the date script,
how much data we are able to recover
from the abrupt failure.
So we'll query date table.
As you can see, like it's 11:45:48.
And we'll summarize in the next slide
how much RPO
we are able to recover
or how much data we are able to recover.
Let's also check the application-level RPO
and RTO integrity with the blog.
So we are able to also see
the blog is also available,
which was just created
before the abrupt scenario.
So what we observe?
So AWS Disaster Recovery
service was successfully able
to recover a Windows-based application
and a SQL-server-based
database application
from an abrupt failure
to a completely recovered state,
which was there in the
original state of application.
This particular process
had, we are able to do,
I mean, nine second of an RPO
and less than 25 minutes of an RTO.
So it was, the job took around 21 minutes,
and then we could take the IS boot up time
because that's where the application
is accessible to the users.
This was with Mumbai and Singapore region,
which is like 4,000 kilometer,
or 2,500 miles, apart.
And distance plays a role in RPO,
as you may know, right?
This is great.
I mean, if you see the Zydus scale,
it has a data center
and multiple plant locations
across the country.
And for that, how,
I mean, what could be the scenario
where they can achieve a less RPO?
Any guesses?
I mean, what could be the important aspect
of NET architecting the solution?
Network architecture.
You may have guessed it right.
So let's look into the
network architecture.
So this is the core foundation
of Zydus disaster recovery solution,
providing resilience, security,
and performance all together.
If you start from the left,
if you see the Zydus
corporate data center,
which was already connected
with all the Zydus plant
before we started this particular
solution implementation.
They already had an
active/passive network,
different network provider connectivity
between their data center
and all the plants.
All the traffic was going
from the plant locations
to the central data center locations.
What we did was we just extended
the existing resilient
network architecture
to AWS Direct Connect,
with a distinct AWS
Direct Connect locations
with the same resilient pattern
with active/passive,
with two different
network service provider.
Here, the key service
is AWS Direct Connect,
which is a secure and
private connectivity service.
Connects between your on-premise
and the cloud environment.
One of the key thing or
design decision we had to make
was after establishing this
particular connectivity,
I mean, in the existing network pattern,
all the disaster recovery
traffic will also go
to the data center,
and then we'll move the cloud.
That would create bandwidth issues
at the data center level.
So what we did is we
designed the network path
such that only the DR replication traffic
will move from the plant location
directly to the AWS
Direct Connect location.
And the rest of the plant traffic
will move on an existing path
of the Zydus corporate path.
So this was a very key decision.
This actually optimized the bandwidth.
Just imagine at a greater scale,
when they add new plants,
this would have created exponential issues
at the bandwidth.
Let's move within the AWS cloud, where,
if you see the service called
AWS Direct Connect Gateway.
So Direct Connect Gateway is a service
where you can connect
to multiple AWS regions.
Just imagine, I mean,
with a single resilient connectivity,
Zydus is now able to connect
to any of the AWS regions.
They don't have to mimic
the same connectivity
for every region, and that is enabled
by the AWS Direct Connect Gateway.
The next key service
is the transit gateway,
which is the central router
and a network segmentation
using hub-and-spoke topology.
This is a very key
service which enables you
for isolating your critical workload
into separate AWS accounts
and virtual private clouds.
If you see here,
from the different network accounts
and the disaster recovery
production account,
and as well as multiple VPCs
having network account,
having disaster recovery,
staging subnets, recovery subnets,
all are isolated for network segmentation,
better security point of view.
Let's deep dive into the overall Zydus
complete disaster recovery solution.
Starting from the left,
we installed the AWS
Disaster Recovery agent
on each source server,
which started replicating encrypted
and compressed block-level data
to this staging subnet.
If you see here,
we have already seen the Direct Connect
and how it is enabled by
the networking services.
Moving to the recovery subnets.
If you see here, the recovery subnet,
there is not a single workload
which is running 24 by 7,
and that has only been
available during disaster recovery drill
or a failover scenario.
Zydus followed a three step of recovery
in the recovery subnet.
In the first step,
they recovered a primary active directory.
It's recovered and configured,
along with a third-party firewall instance
with a pre-configured
Amazon machine image,
which provides additional network security
to their existing disaster
recovery environment.
As you know, like, your data has
to be stable and available
before your application can connect.
And so in the second phase,
all the database servers
were recovered and configured.
And, at last, in the
third stage of recovery,
all the application servers
are recovered and configured.
At last, if you see, I mean,
this is all the overall
network architecture
and the solution architecture.
If you go into the solution now,
let's say what was the
implementation phase, right?
You must have those questions.
So Zydus followed a
structured and phased approach
in their implementation,
starting with establishing a secure
and resilient AWS cloud foundation
we have seen in the previous slides.
Then, after, we started, application-wise
and location-wise,
replicating the data on cloud.
This was in the first phase.
In the second phase, the
replication was completed
of all the application servers
and the database servers, and then
it was extensively tested
for configurations.
This was done in the second phase.
Followed by a phase called as in hypercare
to addressing any unplanned issues.
Hypercare is a temporary phase,
temporary phase where we
provide intensive support
to address any unplanned issues,
like a replication lag,
or a replication backlog,
or, let's say, recovery configurations
which you may encounter during
your extensive testing.
The third phrase, and this is one
of the very critical phase
in terms of implementation,
where we did a centralized monitoring
and automated alerts
for key matrices, like replication lag,
replication backlog,
and network state monitoring,
which is very important
to make sure like the
overall RPO is minimal.
In the same phase,
we have also done solution validation.
So the solution was validated
as per the GxP guidelines to ensure
the data integrity and availability.
Accordingly, Zydus teams have completed
the GxP-compliant solution
validation documentation.
And at the last phase, the solution,
we have done a complete
disaster recovery drill
with complete failover
and failback testing.
As you can see,
within six month of a period,
enterprise-scale complex
solution implementation,
as well as validation,
was completed by the Zydus team.
And this is one of the
outstanding efforts by Zydus IT
and the business teams together.
Here comes one of my favorite section.
Not only, I mean, failed implementation,
even the successful
implementations like this
also teaches us something valuable,
and we would like to summarize
in three key lessons.
The first one, with the cloud foundation,
where Zydus prioritized the secure
and resilient cloud foundation,
as we have seen in the
phase-wise approach.
Why this is important?
And if you ask this question, I mean,
because it ensures that the
DR environment stability
is there throughout,
ensuring the minimal RPO,
which was their key requirement
for implementing the DR solution.
Not only that, that also enabled them
to spin up new workload,
which are in isolated environments,
based on the network
and the security-based architecture.
The second one is here,
where the things was,
I mean, things went interesting.
So while in the second
phase, what we realized
was there were three database servers
which were having consistent
replication lag issues.
And this was very odd
because there are more
than 10 database servers,
and they are very, very, I mean, critical
in terms of the transaction volumes,
but only these three database
servers in their peak times.
Another database server
in their peak times,
also, they were not showing
any replication lag issues.
So Zydus teams, AWS support team,
and as well as the partner teams,
they actually worked together,
deep dive into the issues
in multiple level of diagnosings.
What they figured out
was there was a very extreme change rate
was there on those three database servers.
And just summarizing the resolution
which happened in the stages,
was with configuring
their firewall QS policy,
the corporate QS firewall policy.
Then putting a dedicated
replication servers,
and as well as increasing the IOPs
and the throughput of
those database servers.
Now, you may have a question.
This is a block-level replication,
when you have just
replicated the same disc
or a replicated DR environment.
How come IOPS
and storage throughput can be changed
without changing the storage size?
Because storage size is same
because of the block-level
replication, right?
So AWS has a GP3,
which is the latest volumes,
where you can increase the
IOPS and the throughput
without changing the storage size.
And this was very key in achieving
our solution, also, overall.
Let's move to last one,
lesson learned, monitoring and alerting.
So automated monitoring
and alerting was set up,
you already know, as part
of the phase-wise implementation.
What we observed was certain alerts
were coming quite often,
and due to the nature of the networking,
which is part of the remote sites,
and they were also
automatically getting dissolved.
And so overall governance point of view,
we were getting a lot of
alerts without any insights.
So it was more of an alert
fatigue, you can say.
So what we, as AWS, our AWS partner,
(indistinct) Technologies,
who have actually helped
with the semi-automated
reporting, daily reporting,
which made sure like only
for those set of alerts.
Also, we are not missing the key insights
at the end of a day.
And it helped, actually,
in overall governance.
Though, I mean, this is
part of a single sort of,
or I would say three to four matrixes.
The key learnings from here
is like monitoring and alerting,
making sure like when you are establishing
a complete governance,
you're not missing any
insights out of that.
Certain alerts, if
they're not making sense,
maybe removing it is a better choice.
If they're making sense
and having repeated alert,
like false positives,
then you need to make sure
like you get better insights
with some daily reporting
or maybe early reporting
sort of implementation.
Let's move to like summarize
the transformative disaster
recovery solution implementation
by Zydus.
So, as you can see,
from 24 hours of an RPO
to less than 15 minutes of an RPO,
and 24 to 48 hours of RTO
to less than three hours of an RTO.
All this while not running
any disaster recovery site up and running
or any infrastructure up and running
or without having any operating system
or a database licensing,
which means like no capital investment.
Operationally, also a
very simplified solution
which takes care of your physical servers
and the virtual servers,
all while having completely managed
in an isolated staging area.
And you can do unlimited number
of disaster recovery drills
without impacting your
actually primary environment,
which is very critical for
your regulatory compliances.
So all this was achieved.
Summarizing are the key benefits.
I'm sure, I mean, all these benefits are,
all the benefits are
equally important for Zydus.
However, if I may ask Mr. Ravi
to choose like single benefit
which would like to highlight.
- Yeah, Ashish.
See, you're talking about four benefits,
like no capital investment,
minimal RPO, RTO,
simplified setup, and
security and compliant.
See, so everything is important, right?
But as a finance person, for me,
no capital investment,
or minimum investment
with minimal operational
cost, may be the key.
But I will, without
saying which is better,
I will rate it.
I'll rate maybe no capital
investment is number one.
But, for me, equally important
is minimal RPO, minimal RTO as well
because that is more important
from data point of view,
compliance point of view.
- Thank you.
Thank you very much-
- For your view.
And let's now move into
the last slide of ours.
What's next?
So typical cloud journey starts
with a disaster recovery,
and Zydus has adopted a very strategic
and measured approach
in their cloud journey.
Starting small with disaster recovery,
proving the value,
building the confidence,
and then gradually increasing
the cloud workload.
So they're in advanced stage
of implementing the
cloud-based file service,
having secure and virtually
infinite scale storage
at their plant locations.
They're also, on the generative AI front,
Zydus is investing in
their technical teams
by making them smarter and faster
by using Amazon Q Developer.
And they're also evaluating to move
their non-critical
primary workload on cloud.
So with this, we come
to an end of this session.
Thank you very much for joining us.
And take a moment,
please, and your feedback,
valuable feedback will
be highly appreciated.
Please have that in the AWS events app.
Thank you, again, and enjoy
the rest of the re:Invent.
Thank you.
- Thank you.